I'm just excited everything happens for
a reason I've trained all year for this
moment and people are going to see a new
fighter October 29th Jake Paul making
big promises ahead of his boxing match
against Anderson Silva on Saturday
October 29th when two fighters meet in
Arizona
both already have almost everything that
anyone
anywhere would desire
but get this Jake and Anderson actually
go way back so far back Anderson was the
first celeb a young Jake ever met where
there's no celebrities in Ohio and he
just like happened to be there for some
reason at an MMA fight
um it's very surreal man I just when I
started jumping rope I just like looked
up at the posters here and I just had to
like giggle to myself like this is just
hilarious that we're here and I'm
fighting this guy this is make or break
moment and I know I have someone who
just beat a former world champion boxer
in front of me I don't take him lightly
at all he's the goat of striking he's
the goat of MMA yeah but don't let the
YouTubers kind words fool you that
switch will be turned uh Saturday night
you know and I I'm a professional this
is what I do for a living so it's easy
for me to turn that switch on and Jake
he's channeling another pro athlete
going into the match the late Kobe
Bryant I'm carrying that Mamba mentality
into the ring you know he he knocked
over his teammate Paul Gasol and the
redeemed team he didn't give a sh if
they were cordial or not they just won
the championship and he tackled him in
the sport of basketball so I'm carrying
that Mamba mentality into the fight on
Saturday this is a mega fight
um so yeah I'm excited and and it should
be a really good night
but I always train like I'm fighting the
hardest fighter in the world and he is
one of the hardest fighters in the world
um so I know it's a tough task ahead of
me I'm not underestimating him I just
know what I'm capable of one thing's for
sure Jake he's not horsing around
he's always number one you know it comes
before all of the business stuff it
comes before all of the content stuff so
when I wake up in the morning I'm
focused on boxing
[Music]